short stream this
evening uh I'm going to show you what
I've been working on
today and we're going to
hopefully maybe get it working I don't
know it's a big ask but uh we're at
least going to make some progress
right hey welcome it's been pretty good
working on some stuff with a colleague
and
uh I also got some cool stuff written
today uh what I have to do first
right so what I've been working on
today is getting these layers into
C I have this working this is tested
this matches P torch so we have a
convolution in PC that works uh and now
all I have to do is get the lstm done I
already have the linear layer done and
if I can do that then we will be able to
run the entire policy that I'm using for
the Moa for all the M's basically we've
mostly standardized on this type of
policy uh in PC which means we can run
it on the web so we'll be able to
upgrade the AI of all of our web demos
we'll be able to make this cool thing
hold on so I put this out yesterday
these guys aren't doing anything right
now well we have ourl policies for them
and if I can just get them into C then
we'll have RL teammates to you know play
this awesome little mobile with me
right all
right so there are a few things that
have been bothering me
here let's get the pie torch docks up we
have to exactly match the pytorch
reference implementation is the other
hard thing with
this no not
lspm so this is the pytorch
lstm uh the way that they have it
implemented and I've also I've checked
internally uh how they have their
weights represented so we'll just leave
this as a
reference you can see here I have two
different linear layers this is for
this portion so all of these Ops
actually these are done with two big
weight matrices so this is pretty much
solved but then the tricky part is like
there's an intermediate buffer
here so here's this output buffer and
now we have to figure out we have to
figure out a couple things on how to
apply the activations I
believe yeah so
batch yeah this is actually kind of hard
because the dimensions don't match up
the way that we would want them
to
um yeah the dimensions do not match up
the way we would want them to
so because this is a batched
operation right we
have batch by like some hidden Dimension
um what I'd like to be able to do is
like apply like you know uh sigmoid
sigmoid T sigmoid or whatever on
different portions of the output buffer
but the dimensions are wrong for that if
I try to do it that way
I'm going to end up
applying yeah I'm going to end up
applying stuff to the wrong data so I
think I actually have to write out these
Loops manually which is obnoxious
but probably not bad if I'm thinking
about it
now
right hidden
size the output buffer should be of Si
of hidden size right
yes okay so I think all I have to do
this is not as bad as I
ignore all
right hey linky
I guess what I want to do is if I were
just going to be naive around this
right this will just be in
B kind of lost so I take along so I'll
tell so let me give you this guys just a
brief overview of what I'm doing here um
so P torch defines all these nice layers
for us right but the problem is that if
we want to run this on the web
like I can't run pytorch on here right
there's a python binding there's kind of
there's a C++ API none of it'll run on
the web um now there are some bigger
libraries and things out there that kind
of can let you run stuff on the web but
I figur that the simplest thing to do
would just be to like Implement a few of
these layers in C and if I Implement
them in C I can compile them to run on
the web so all I have to do is I have to
just write this in C it doesn't have to
be crazy fast it just has to be fast
enough to run
inference so that's what I'm doing now
this is some math
um but this is fairly standard and I'm
just trying to replicate this here in
see okay so the way that this works now
is python is yeah exactly so the way
that this works is uh for each batch for
each element in the batch there's going
to be this line of numbers that is four
times the hidden size uh and what I need
to do
so let's just
do how about we do uh
inline
sigmoid let's do
tanic we actually don't need to because
this is a built-in function so we
actually only need
sigmoid okay so now for these two all I
have to do is
output in
uh
offset is going to be
four
time four time batch time hidden size is
going to be the offset into this array
and
then
output
buffer offset plus I hold
on uh this is completely
wrong it's sigmoid
wrong doesn't need to be multiplied like
this
yet I think I see what it's trying to do
we're going to leave it like this for
now all right so
what I just did is I just did these two
activation functions these two sigmoids
here and then I have to
do this is going to be two
* uh hidden
size all right and then this is going to
be the tan
h y this is tan H here
and then I think this should just auto
complete yeah look it literally knows
what an lstm is that's
funny and there might be some way of
improving this later but here are all of
our
activations and now the thing that we
have to do so we've done all these lines
and now what we have to figure out are
these two lines at the bottom um
which should not be hard I don't
think yeah these should not be
hard yeah very easy so these
activations and
now uh these are
Gates is this actually going to do this
correctly I'm curious
this
I plus G
welcome we're doing some ridiculous
stuff today
the lstm is the easy part
actually this monstrosity was the hard
part I've been watching 231n good I
highly highly highly recommend doing
some of the assignments for
it basically they'll have you do this
but way less painful because it's going
to be in Python with
numpy that's what that course like
that's what the assignments
are of course they also make you do ad
autograd which is very painful
but commute to work
yeah it'll take some getting used to
it's definitely something that's worth
spending the time on
though uh like if you just if you
understand everything in that course
you'll understand more than like 90% of
the dumbass uh AI like AI engineers in
Silicon
Valley Okay so
[ __ ] more than me yeah w
you could do the course
free it's not output buffer right
it's output cell yeah
CNM
hey check this com implementation then
right I checked this against P torch
today this is
ass okay so output cell
uh
of again I got to stop taking these
suggestions they're wrong so this is
going to
be float
gate which is
Ft so this is going to be
output
buffer B offset Plus
hidden size plus
I
plus
output this is I
gate
times let me know when you push to
GitHub so I can sit my PR per default
doesn't get lost
yeah we'll
do here summary on lstm
what like just what an lstm is
or what's going on I just got okay yeah
so uh the the short version of this if
you know what like basic layers are um
I'm what I'm doing now is I'm
implementing the I'm implementing uh
convolutions and long shortterm memory
from pytorch exactly this is way it's
implemented in pytorch in PRC so that I
can compile it to web assembly and run
it online so that I can like have
reinforcement learning agents in your
Stanford lectures online yes 231n is
online I recommend Andre's or Justin
lectors they're both good also drinking
a protein shake very good good 80 grams
of
protein this is unflavored way isolate
with like two or two or three cups of
whole milk and a cup of chocolate
milk gate wait
I B offset plus
I this is two times hidden
size plus I that doesn't sound like
coffee it's six 30m here linky I'm
already plenty
caffinated okay I think this is actually
it on the output
cell and then all we have to do is
the do we need output State I don't
think we need output State I think we
can just have
like this
right output
cell thank you recently graduated CS
want to self study saw your thesis
defense got motivated started to read
I haven't seen this one dive into deep
learning let me see if this is any
good well it looks like it's well
used oh yeah okay I know Lipton I've met
him uh that's cool
that's
cool definitely recommend cs231n I don't
know if there's better stuff by now but
it's quite good just an online book oh
okay I see online book got
it did you end up checking I haven't
checked out Welch Labs what is on there
that I should look
at I've been freaking coding man I've
been coding and coding
buffer B offset
plus three times hidden State plus
I
cell any good any resource is good to
keep in backlog 230 231 and yeah that's
I I pretty much did that and just
immediately started doing research like
there weren't as good resources back
then to be
fair but
yeah I will tell you that
the the back propop implementations for
like con and batchnorm and a few of the
things are God awful it's not fun um
it's kind of a right of passage more
than
anything but it course teaches you
really
everything oh deep learning book I see
yeah yeah yeah I've heard of
that I think we actually have the lsdm
implemented though this is I mean this
is what it should look like whether this
is correct or not we'll have to see the
com I know is correct but this is not
that bad for a whole lstm
right and like this would have been
cleaner but this like the indexing here
is a little annoying
let's just rename I don't like this
output buffer I think this is just like
buffer that'll make it a little
cleaner like these lines are too long
technically I there are refactor
shortcuts but I don't remember if I
named anything else output buffer in
this
file and this was quick okay so not bad
at all not bad at
all talks about Alex mat WS if well put
together AI narration definitely help
elaborate very educational not needed
this stage yeah worth for educational
entertainment yeah fair enough fair
enough I've implemented so many basic
Nets like so many times at this point
yeah it's been a bunch of years but
still I mean the fact that I was able to
do this in a day
all right so we have this com layer
right and now we need the lstm layer uh
so what we're going to do here
okay
so
oops um
input bch size batch size
16 input size equal I think it's it is
it
128 I'm pretty sure it's 128 input size
well we can use that regardless though I
just have to write like a little unit
test type
thing and we'll be able to improve on
this in the future like maybe like we'll
be able to make all this stuff way
simpler I just want to get it to be
correct for
now num
input
okay num uh
buffer batch size time
time four it's four time batch size time
hidden size because lstms have four
Gates num output is going to be batch
size time hidden
size
right yeah okay so we'll
do a float star input is going to be
allocate input we'll do buffer is
allocate of
buffer output cell is going to be output
output State going to be allocated like
this then float
star uh what is it
weights
input hidden size times input
size uh it's four times this isn't it
size oh I forgot an operation
what are Gates noes that perform a
mathematical operation talk about Gates
how they're using backrop descent uh
this is this is something you'll see
later uh essentially the architecture of
an lstm has several mathematical
operations to alter the way in which
different data is combined that are
referred to as Gates
um yeah
this is different this is not just like
your reu AC which is really an
activation these are like the input gate
the forget gate the something gate I
forget and output gate like these have
these all have different names in a
fancy ass
architecture I don't
know maybe
gate uh weight input
here well this is the correct weight
size so we'll do
that wait state
bias
input bias actually these are not
supposed to be allocated though these
are going to have to be
pointers so we'll have to figure these
out these are supposed to be
pointers
Rock I was referring to like rock like
the language modeler like to just you
know just rock it just get
it was a
joke that's funny if you explain
it and not that funny in the first
place but so so this is correct uh we're
going to have to do
and that is incredibly obnoxious isn't
it
I'm going to defer this loading bit for
now I think
because yeah I'm going to defer the
loading bit for now and I'm just going
to allocate the weight
so the goal of this is to be able to
load the weights from a trained P torch
model and then be able to do the
inference setup in pure C in like you
know two 300 lines whatever this ends up
being of just pure C
State let's just put this in let's just
call this state
State bias
input bias
State output
cell buffer batch input okay cool
um we have to allocate these weights
though don't we
well are you tracking State sequences
with the
lstm will there be a
sequence uh the way it works in this
because this is just for inference uh
and it we only need one state at a time
you just need the previous state in
order to get the next one you don't need
to have a sequence and run it this is
not a uh this is not like a supervised
like sequence to sequence model or
something like that it's just you use
the lstm to remember the previous date
and you roll it out one step at a
time pretty much the um
when you need to have the whole sequence
at once is when you're doing training
since it's it's a little simpler because
we just have to do
inference but it's not very simple
because it's in C
I'm sure I'm going to regret just
putting all these to like a range like
one through nend data but we'll do this
for
now and uh yeah we'll see if this
actually does anything
oops right this is
this
and we have overflow because right I
forgot that there's okay so there's a
thing that I did wrong here in the
lstm which is actually not going to be a
fun time um
sh I totally forgot about this didn't
I handling case State
sequences like hood of a player entering
a certain State
see hold on I'm trying to figure this
thing out
here
uh so this is quite obnoxious
because this is expecting this is
expecting an input that's four times
longer
actually I think for now I should I just
allocate this as an intermediate
like technically there are ways to make
this way faster is the funny thing about
it
um but it's fine
like we'll just have to
allocate what the buffer
storing so like right here the way that
this gets implemented uh you have to
concatenate x with itself you have to
concat the input with it self um like a
bunch of times I think is that right or
am I being dumb hold
yeah the way this is usually implemented
um if I recall you can catenate the
input with itself four times and you can
catenate the state with itself four
times and then you do it all in one big
matrix
multiplication pretty sure that's yeah
that's how it's
done so I have to do that now which is
obnoxious
let's just add like a parameter input
buffer for now I'm only going to be on
here for another hour or so short stream
[Music]
today just tuning in today can you give
me a quick high level what you're
currently grinding on sure this is a
pretty shortterm thing but uh
essentially I've got on the puffer
website I'm starting to accumulate some
games like this guy here these are RL
agents running in your browser but
they're pretty stupid because they're
just running uh an
MLP like in order for this to work we've
got like this more complex MOBA game the
policy I use for this is uh a convet and
an
lstm and I need to be able to run that
on the web so I can't run P torch on the
web so what I'm doing at the moment is
I'm just uh I'm just
converting a few different pytorch
layers into pure C so that I can run
them on the web
so like this is an lstm I'm implementing
in C I already got the linear layer some
of the gates and the com layer so
basically as soon as I finish this lstm
and clean stuff up a bit we'll be able
to code up uh the network that I want in
order to run the full end to end demo on
the web so like you can train your
pytorch model locally and then you can
just load the weights into this network
and then it'll run on the web 100%
client side
why isn't there already a CP torch
Library I don't know man there should
be I couldn't find any that I liked I
couldn't find anything like reasonable
it shouldn't be that hard like as you
can see this is yeah it's obnoxious but
this is going to end up being like two
300 lines of code it's not that bad B
sounds dope yeah it's
fun if you have a particularly
masochistic definition of fun is as I do
at
least centerflow JS Works in
browser yeah but I'm training stuff in
pytorch I need it to match the P torch
reference um and also I would literally
rather write C than ever touch
honest oh actually I don't need to
allocate this do I this need to allocate
and also like we we don't really need
the JavaScript look this whole
environment is in C this whole
environment just runs in
C and I I I honestly and truly believe
it was easier than if I tried to write
it in
JavaScript maybe that's crazy but
it okay now we have an input buffer
right so now all I have to do is I have
to
replicate
struct
uh replica input
replicas
input
buffer I do not like
this I don't like that logic at
all maybe that is actually better
because it's writing to
contiguous
memory
uh do we really have to do
that hey do you have any learning
resources to about rlms rappers other
technical stuff have you seen my latest
video
ads yeah yeah yeah yeah go away
Brock okay
so this video here is 26 minutes goes
through all the different layers of the
RL stack and uh gives you a decent
overview if you want to get a little bit
deeper in there is a white paper
with some additional references in here
that you can look at uh and then from
there M's wrappers and other technical
stuff if you want really the infr layer
you're in the right place because I'm
building all that stuff live and uh if
you want to do some of it Hands-On you
can help out by building some M's uh for
puffer because we act we definitely need
more environments we have a few people
implementing like different Atari m in
uh doesn't have to be C it can be like
scyon or whatever um just ultra high
performance M for training yep watched
it thank
you yeah so you're definitely in the
right place and actually this offer goes
for everyone watching here um if you
want to build like ultra high perf Ms
it's a lot easier than it looks you
don't have to write them in C scon is
fine if you don't know scon it literally
reads like python with a couple types
added um it's very very easy
and I want to show some examples but
Discord doesn't want to
cooperate uh what I was going to show is
a few different environments that people
have been building in the dev channel
here uh if you build some M's like I
will review code and help on Stream So
that offer goes for whatever the only
stipulation has to be like an open
sourced M that we're going to actually
be able to integrate with
puffer okay uh
Dev I think they're in
general so we have somebody implementing
a more complex en here that's really
cool this based on Old
MMO we have I wanted to show off like
the pong and the breakout M's though
because these are like very very
achievable projects for
people okay like here somebody has a
version of pong that just runs stupidly
fast and then somebody has a version of
breakout that runs stupidly
fast yeah somebody made a dopus retro M
yeah they're working on it they're going
to get back to it next week I'm actually
really surprised to see the number of
people that know that game I have like
three or 4,000 hours in that game from
when when I was
younger I probably have like 10 level
190 to
200s across all the different versions
of the
game is every French yeah well in the US
nobody knows it
right I forgot we also need State buffer
here don't we that's obnoxious
and I had a lot of fun with that game
growing up
that's such a good
game nisha's robotics RL perer Li plan
to cover that yep so it's a newer thing
for us we're expanding into it but uh
you should follow I'll show you who you
should follow for
this give Kung a follow he's uh he is
the one who's currently integrating
robotic stuff with puffer um and like
he's basically solved some of the majoko
m just via hyper parameter tuning with
puffer going Ultra fast
and we're definitely looking to add
bindings for more so either bindings for
existing M's or you know from scratch
ultra high perf
at kung's done a lot of amazing work
around for uh around for uh for Nur Mo
and Puffer definitely should give him a
follow he do cool stuff thank you for
streaming on YouTube it's rare one I
despise twitch we're currently here on
YouTube twitch and uh X at the same time
so just pick wherever
right most of the audience is on YouTube
though we have a few on Twitch now as
well
K is very nice and helpful yeah kung's
awesome he does some awesome
stuff uh this should be input buffer
here weight buffer and then this is uh
State buffer
right do I have to replicate the bias as
well hold on
do you need to stack the
bias I'm actually having a hard time
visualizing
so no you don't need to stack the bias
because the bias is already allocated uh
to to the correct Dimension so we're
good now but what we do need to do is
it's batch size uh input size it's going
to be four times input size
right bat size four times hidden size
and then you go to four
times
right cuz
yeah that should be
wait a
there cuz you're not doing the full
Matrix moles
right it's not like a block Matrix um
CNN LS
TMC wassom web assembly so we can run it
on the
you're
good this is embarrassing here not being
able to
freaking visualize
am I wrong in thinking that it's
implemented this
X yeah wait can this even be implemented
as one big mole
because wait
index what the thing I'm confused here
is hold
on there's like a trick that you do with
an with an
lstm I might have done this in my old
code
actually I might literally have
uh where's
so no I think that it's not here maybe
it would be in a Baseline
FC wait is it four
times
oh yeah I'm real
dumb yeah yeah yeah real real dumb okay
you actually don't need need the input
buffers uh you don't need the input
buffers at all I got the shapes
wrong yeah you don't need to do any of
this
[ __ ] let me just make sure let me make
sure I'm
positive so the way it works is that you
have you just you make the hidden State
four times larger than you need so you
can adjust based on that that's
literally all it is yeah we don't need
this
okay which is actually good that
simplifies stuff very substantially in
fact can I just like undo a
okay yeah that was my bad
so the thing that I screwed up here is
way easier it's literally just
all of course we'll have to still debug
some stuff
right let's see MOA
27 line 100
here read of size
four input gate you don't need the input
buffers yeah no so the way it works let
me explain something so the way that an
lstm is written
here uh it looks like you have different
weight matrices Wii wi right it looks
like you have eight different weight
matrices but actually you only need two
because what you do is let's say your
input Dimension is
128 right what you do is you make a
linear layer from 128 to 512 and then
you split it into chunks so you only
need one weight Matrix and you get to
batch the computation and then you do
the same thing with the second set of
Weights so you only have you've got two
128x 512 matrices for a 128 dimensional
uh input basically that's how that works
and I was just getting confused uh for
some reason I thought that you had to
stack the input instead of the weights
my bad uh yeah there you
go now uh this is still failing for some
reason here so let's figure this
out
input yeah M subm
exactly
[Music]
so hidden size times input
size so this is going to be four
times uh four four times input
have we're still erroring
here let me recheck the dimensions we
know that this linear layer
implementation is correct
C
Alec input is
128 well what the hell are we doing we
didn't allocate we didn't multiply by oh
wait we did no we did multiply by the
batch size
okay num
state okay and then input
is hidden
size looks good to
yeah oh look at that it crashes way
lower now now we get all the way down to
Here Without uh without seg
falting and now I just have to think
about my indexing a little
bit line it says on
54 so
here input of B offset plus I
plus
I and
buffer and then here this
State o
tan output
cell input
offset plus
I where do we fail
okay so we still fail here this is input
offset
runs we'll see whether it's correct
we'll have to test it but it
runs solid
achievement I'm using rest from real
quick then I'm going to order food and
then in the next 20 30 minutes while I'm
waiting for that we're going to try to
test it and see if it actually is
correct uh and if so then we will commit
this and then basically already tomorrow
uh we'll definitely be able to get some
networks running which is awesome I'll
be right
okay commit this before I'm screwing
anything
now this is where things
are a little tricky
potentially to test
go we're need to go into here and we're
going to need to
do uh a separate type of uh a test
comment
128 128
lstm and what we're going to have to do
is for. from
PI let's just also
add B size
this actually just do
it h good job super
solid now the thing is that this does
not need these buffers anymore so it's a
little screwy
there
but what we want to
see we have state and we have output
like there are two different inputs here
did I use these
correctly no I didn't use these
correctly did
I okay we have to change a couple small
things we'll finish this first but
there's a couple small things I got to
order my food as
well
um
yeah kind of on a roll here though I'm
kind of
like I'll wait another 10
minutes
whatever
here so now we have
state
right
output eight
okay
inputs this also is a
zero wait
really input
State what the heck
[Music]
uh what's the input
size 16
correct
l
hn oh uh I think we need to use lstm
cell
yeah we need to use like lstm cell I
believe
and then what do we have to do we have
to do
like that first
input so obnoxious that like it's not
batched first
you just have to add a one to the start
of these don't
you I think it's literally that easy
it's just one one one like this
cool so you actually have uh you
actually have your data now
perfect
um I got to go fix one thing in the C
code I
believe uh I am actually starting to get
hungry so I'm going to go order some
food on the side and we'll fix the C and
then we'll fix the
C I messed up one one thing about how I
treat
what do I let me figure out what I want
to get real quick and then we'll
continue this
this cool so now we will do uh we will
go back to this food stuff makes the
dude PFF
that and waits my
friend that and
waits today was supposed to be light day
for some squats but I was low on time so
I couldn't do a bunch of sets so my dumb
ass decided to do a set of 20 squats
with just a plate like yeah it's just a
plate right nope terrible idea
absolutely terrible
terrible idea terribly great
idea I mean look I have even I have
limits on the masochism
okay High rep squats and deadlifts are
one of those
limits now I say that being uh editing
this monstrosity
so I realized that I messed up the way
that we get the uh the state
information so this state here this numb
output State actually has two components
so I got to do it like this
and yeah so the way that this is going
to be handled let me see if if there's
an easy way to cheat
this actually that's really bad isn't
it yeah you can't concatenate the two
components of the state because you'll
screw up along the batching Dimension
okay so this actually has to be
State at state was it
C State
H
um that's ABN
just okay and then we will set uh the
state just some initial
data and
now where do we use stage
So currently we just use State
here and then at the
bottom which means we actually don't
need output cell do
we yeah we don't need output cell at
all that's nice
we just need the state the state will be
in place for
now I'm considering we'll probably make
like some strs and stuff uh to help
manage all the memory for these at some
point but for now we're just passing
around
pointers okay we have these states and
then the linear accumulate
here it's cell State hidden
HC
yeah so I have these backwards
that's
important okay and now that I have these
states all I have to do is this one here
is going to be State
H and then at the bottom here this is
not output cell
output cell is actually going to be
State
C and then this is State
H and then this is State
errors this paramet is gone
now I'm going to put these I'm hoping
this isn't coming through the mic but
the screaming kids outside are driving
me
nuts
um hopefully I have good enough noise
reduction for
that uh weights
input weight State this has to be State
H State C now right and we
will format this
runs okay so this uh we don't know if
it's correct yet but we do know that at
least it's not uh it's not seg fting and
we have a dress sanitizer on so we're
not writing out of bounds anywhere on
this
test so now what we can do for the next
little bit until food gets here and I
got to go will be uh we will see see if
we can make sure that this uh lstm
implementation matches the pytorch
reference
implementation uh now that's going to be
a little bit tricky to
do but I think we should be
okay yeah so we're going to essentially
have to manually check a couple things
so I have here uh just this dummy lstm
where I have taken the
data and I want to make sure that this
thing matches the way I think that it it
is implemented we have output comma New
State right and what I'm going to do
here is I'm going to try to implement
this thing manually so I'm going to
do like
um what's this
hold
on let me see how I implemented it here
we're going to match it very
buffer okay so what we're going to do is
we're going to do buffer
equals and then it's weights
so torch. mat
Mo weights
zero plus
bias
input
plus M
mole okay so what we're doing here is we
have
right this is the same operation as we
just implemented in C but using torch
map moles
right and
then what we need to do is
let's check like
buffer star two
times hidden
size
times okay so these are the
activations and then we'll what we do is
C
equals f
is
buffer three * hidden size actually we
can we can make this easier on ourselves
right and we can do
ifg equals torch. split buffer hidden
size
right this is actually so much easier we
we just do it up
here and then what we'll just do is I
sigmoid can H like this yeah that's so
much cleaner fire and now we just do c
is going to
be ha how it spaces automatically for
you like I always perceptually group
stuff like this
and O *
T and uh
perfect so this is it really
so we we have to do first here is figure
out
backwards I think the maps
backwards first let's see if this
matches what we think it should match uh
uh essentially The lstm Works the way we
think it
does oh State this is state of
maybe uh wait maybe this declaration is
the wrong
way way we had it correct before with
the map mole
a at
B yeah it doesn't solve the
problem this is the in wait four times
hidden size is the output
Dimension this looks correct to
me let me see what's wrong
this like technically I can transpose
the input
right I'm just going to transpose the
input and I'm going to assume like I
know I have their linear layer
implemented correctly so I think that
they're just they're doing their data
structures
huh I also don't like how I ended up
with the uh the wrong Dimensions here
right
I think I should transpose the weights
instead
okay we'll just do HC is New State
right this is just going to be
H and we'll just do
input
output okay these do not
match so that's not
values that's kind of suspicious though
I guess it's like we have some repeating
data patterns so maybe that's just
nothing M Mo input and
weights
moles f
time
C+ I *
G HTS o t HC that looks
correct oh
I'm trying to think how I can even test
this because like the problem is that
the lstm unlike the other things I've
been testing is very monolithic
and like I have to match their
implementation
c yeah perfect this matches okay we're
good we got it
so this now we know that the P torch
implementation is Saye we have the uh
the C implementation so now let's see
how far food is and uh we'll debug until
food is here hold
on oh well it's here um okay I got to
get my food then uh of course there some
YouTube folks join but tomorrow what we
will do with this I'm going to commit
this for now you guys can play with if
you
want so what we're going to do
tomorrow at the
start is we are going to go go through
this lstm code and we're going to like
step by step we're going to go through
the data and we're going to see whether
the P torch implementation matches the C
implementation and if that if all of
that works then we'll probably write
some sort of like little test so that we
can make sure that we're not going to
break it going forward we will figure
out probably some way to put these
layers uh into strs or something cuz
like some of them require buffers and
other things and like these signatures
are really long and annoying so we'll
probably make some sort of lstm struct
thing and like some sort of layer struct
thing um maybe a tensor will decide on
that uh and then we'll have like this
nicely cleaned up and we will implement
the CNN lstm MLP architecture that is
used in our Baseline models that way we
can take our game which is online here
all of our games really they all use
very similar models and uh instead of me
just playing this thing alone I will be
able to play it against you know all of
our fun little agent friends you can try
this out at puffer AI giab puffer AI GI
habo I will be on tomorrow early
afternoon PST at the latest and if
you're just seeing this project and such
for the first time the goal here is to
make reinforcement learning Ultra fast
and easy we're 20 Stars off of a th it's
all open source so if you want to help
me out for free start the
repository support on this has been
great and uh yeah we're going to have a
bunch of really awesome like games that
run on web that have reinforcement
learning working ultra high perf very
very soon so thank you all and uh I will
catch you tomorrow